nach mehreren militärischen einsätzen in
der region afrika im nordwesten syriens
marschierte die türkei am 9 oktober 2009
10 auch im nordosten des landes ein
ankara möchte mit eigenen kräften und
verbündeten das grenzgebiet
kontrollieren heute in vechta kompakt
türkische pufferzone in syrien ankara
drängt schon länger auf eine pufferzone
an seiner südgrenze
sie soll sich von der irakischen grenze
bis zum euphrat erstrecken und auf
syrischem boden eingerichtet werden drei
gründe werden dafür angeführt erstens
sicherung des grenzgebietes vor
angriffen durch kurdische pkk kräfte für
die türkei ist die pkk der größte
verändert zweitens verhinderung eines
kurdischen korridors vom irak bis idlib
im nordwesten syriens und drittens
rückführung von bis zu 2.000.000
syrischer flüchtlinge aus der türkei
es befinden sich noch immer über
dreieinhalb millionen im nachbarland
präsident erdogan will ihnen mindestens
32 kilometer breiten streifen mit
mehreren beobachtungsposten
dort sollen sich keine kämpfer der
kurdischen jpg die ankara als pkk
ableger einstuft aufhalten dürfen
ebenso müssen schwere waffen und
verteidigungsanlagen verboten werden
allerdings kann die türkei das nicht
ohne russland entscheiden mosca verhielt
sich vorerst zurückhaltend beim treffen
von putin und erdogan am 22 oktober ist
es aber anscheinend zu einer einigung
gekommen
den kämpfern der jpg wurde mehr zeit für
einen abzug gegeben und nach ihre
entwaffnung soll mit russisch türkischen
patrouillen begonnen werden
die usa wiederum waren verbündete der
kurden im sogenannten rosa war dass
diese sei 2012 selbst verwalten
nur mit deren kampf kräftiger
unterstützung konnte die
terror-organisation es militärisch
besiegt werden
präsident frank zieht aber sukzessive
die us-soldaten aus dem gebiet ab und
versucht durch wirtschaftlichen druck
das vorgehen der türkei zu beeinflussen
dabei nimmt washington in kauf dass der
ie es wieder erstarkt dass es seine
einflussmöglichkeiten in syrien
gänzlich verliert und als unzuverlässig
da steht das assad-regime lehnt eine
türkische pufferzone kategorisch ab
vielmehr möchte es wieder die kontrolle
über das gesamte stadtgebiet erlangen
das verhalten washington spielt ihm
dabei in die hände
die ehemals von den usa unterstützten
syrischen demokratischen kräfte sind
zersplittert
sie bestehen auf der territorialen
integrität syriens und fordern autonomie
der rückzug der usa zwang die kurden
azad um beistand zu suchen
somit können syrische sicherheitskräfte
kampflos in das kurdengebiet
zurückkehren eine pufferzone wirft aber
grundlegende fragen auf so werde als
erstes festzulegen was damit
grundsätzlich erreicht werden soll und
wer verantwortlich ist
dann sollten in einem übereinkommen
anfang und voraussichtliches ende des
einsatzes die aufgaben und kompetenzen
der kräfte und deren einsatzgebiet
geregelt werden denn danach richten sich
die zusammensetzung die art und der
umfang der eingesetzten truppe dazu
gehört zum beispiel welches land kräfte
stellt ob es sich um polizei grenzschutz
oder um militär handelt und ob
luftstreitkräfte vorgesehen sind
zwingend werde auch der umgang mit
inhaftierten es kämpfern und deren
frauen und kindern zu klären
außerdem wäre festzulegen wie mit den
gruppierungen vor ort umzugehen ist die
gegen vereinbarungen verstoßen
zur aktuellen situation mit dem räumlich
begrenzten angriff hat präsident erdogan
die initiative ergriffen
er setzt dabei auf arabische verbündete
vor ort als bodentruppen die von
türkische militär durch luftangriffe und
artilleriefeuer unterstützt werden damit
ist es bereits gelungen das von den
kurden kontrollierte gebiet zu teilen
die jpg zurückzudrängen und die chancen
der kurden auf autonomie zu schmälern
deshalb konnte ankara dem druck der usa
nachgeben und hat vorerst den angriff
gestoppt gelingt es noch zahlreiche
syrische flüchtlinge in diesem streifen
anzusiedeln
hätte er drang seine ziele zumindest in
ansätzen schon erreicht die einrichtung
einer dauerhaften pufferzonen wie von
deutschlands verteidigungsministerin
vorgeschlagen bleibt aber noch offen
es ist anzunehmen dass ankara im
hintergrund intensiv mit dem kreml
verhandelt um eine gesamtlösung zu
finden denn die kämpfe in der westlichen
region idleb toben weiter und es gilt
die interessen russlands syriens und der
türkei unter einen hut zu bringen
ein ausblick die einrichtung einer
pufferzone wird die tagesordnung weiter
bestimmen sie wird in irgendeiner form
kommen aber wie umfangreich sie ist wie
weit sie funktioniert und ob damit er
die erwartungen erfüllt werden bleibt
abzuwarten
unsicher ist auch ob örtliche kräfte
dagegen kämpfen werden sollten
ausländische kräfte die zone übernehmen
so würde das die souveränität syriens
dauerhaft einschränken und das autonomie
streben der kurden massiv
beeinträchtigen die ansiedelung von
flüchtlingen in dieser zone wäre ein
weiterer beitrag zur gezielten
verteilung der syrischen bevölkerung
sollte allerdings die pufferzonen von
einer internationalen friedenstruppe
übernommen werden so könnte das den
auftakt für eine nachkriegsordnung in
syrien bedeuten